this Hogwarts Legacy have any shot to
win game of the year no I don't think so
shut up
now wait wait wait wait before you smash
that dislike button let me explain why
and also tell you why I think Hogwarts
Legacy is going to do something even
better even greater than winning game of
the year so I'm gonna pull here on our
community page that more than 5 000 of
you voted in asking what's your game of
the year so far we had Diablo 4 at 2
Star field at 12 tears of the Kingdom at
25 and Baldur's Gate 3 in the lead at 37
24 of you which would be third place and
just behind tears of the Kingdom voted
for the other category the comments were
filled with responses of Hogwarts Legacy
Hogwarts Legacy a little title called
Hogwarts Legacy and yes more Hogwarts
Legacy now this isn't too big a surprise
considering all the Hogwarts Legacy
videos I've posted here on the channel
and how many of you watching probably
subscribed here just because of our
coverage for that game but even so I
found myself a little surprised to see
so many still saying it was Game of the
Year then again to be totally fair here
the poll question never asks what you
think will win game of the year it asks
for your personal game of the year now
Hogwarts Legacy should absolutely be
recognized for resonating with so many
people and even reaching a vast number
of people who aren't traditional Gamers
some people even bought a console just
for this game I know that for a fact
from hearing from you guys here in the
comments but also people in my real life
my wife is a nurse and she worked with
some fellow nurses who were big Harry
Potter fans who literally bought
PlayStation 5s for this game and that's
something I think the industry as a
whole hasn't really given Hogwarts
Legacy an avalanche enough credit for
they had an absolutely Monumental task
of making a game that would resonate
with so many different audiences with
vastly different expectations and for
the most part they did an incredible job
at that so if Hogwarts Legacy is your
personal favorite game of the year Heck
if it's your favorite game ever made
that's totally fine and 100 your opinion
if we pull back a bit though to look at
the industry as a whole I don't see
Hogwarts Legacy having much of a chance
frankly I'm not even sure we'll see many
nominations I think it's important for
me here on the channel to try and remain
at least somewhat objective and I say
somewhat because it's pretty much
impossible for someone to be completely
objective when it comes to this stuff
after all it's all based on opinions
anyway and don't get me wrong I love
Hogwarts Legacy it's one of my favorite
games ever made covering that game
posting all our theories building the
community we have here it's something
I'll never forget when it comes to
evaluating the game though from a
critical perspective actually think back
to the Harry Potter series as a whole
it's my personal favorite book series
ever for what it means to me when I read
them in my life and what it still means
to me to this day I doubt anything will
ever be able to top that that experience
of reading those seven books for the
first time and everything that went with
it in terms of the fandom but do I think
critically that it's the best written
book series ever well no there certainly
works with more eloquent Pros stronger
characters and some with even more
imaginative worlds which I know is hard
to think about and I feel totally
comfortable acknowledging that and at
the same time saying I don't care it's
still my favorite series ever and I
would pick it over anything else so it's
Hogwarts Legacy though one of the
absolute best overall games of the year
when compared to the others well that's
where things start to get dicey because
this year has just been absolutely
insane for top Notch video games if we
look at the game awards description for
game of the year it reads quote
recognizing a game that delivers the
absolute best experience across all
creative and Technical fields in 2023
has widely been recognized as one of the
best years in the history of video games
it's downright jaw dropping guys I mean
look at this we got tears of the Kingdom
Jedi Survivor Baldur's Gate 3 Diablo 4
Final Fantasy XV Pikmin 4 and Starfield
all in the same year but hold on that's
not it we also had the remix of Dead
Space Resident Evil 4 and Metroid Prime
games that were already recognized as
some of the best ever made and now we
had these top-notch remakes then there's
also Street Fighter 6 Mortal Kombat 1
sea of stars armored Core 6 Remnant 2
and well I think by now you get the
picture well you might be surprised to
learn however is that every single one
of those titles I just mentioned every
single one of them actually scored
higher than Hogwarts Legacy based on
review scores alone what's insane is
that Legacy was no slouch it ended up
finishing with a meta score of 84 and a
fan score of 8.6 both of which are very
respectable numbers now as I was doing
the research for this video one
interesting note is that I found a lot
of those games I mentioned that even
though they scored higher in the
critical reviews Hogwarts Legacy was
still doing much better in the fan
review so that's something also to take
into account but the fact that so many
games ranked above it on the critical
side I think is simply a testament to
the sheer amount of quality games that
were released in 2023 so the nominees
for Jeff keeley's game awards and I do
think it's important to note that many
sites and journalists do their own game
awards but for keeley's selection
process the nominees are quote chosen by
an international jury of over 100 Global
media and influencer Outlets selected
for their history of critical video game
evaluation now that was last year's they
don't have it posted for this year just
yet it may be slightly different but I
think it'll be close to the same last
year the game awards had six nominees
for Game of the Year a plague tale
Requiem God of War Ragnarok Horizon
forbidden West stray Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 and of course the ultimate
winner Elden ring this year I would
expect that tears of the kingdom and
Baldur's game 3 are absolute locks to
receive Game of the Year nominations and
if I'm being totally honest here I think
one of those ends up taking home the
victory right now even though I haven't
played it I think I'd give a slight Edge
to Baldur's Gate 3 based on what I've
been hearing for how much it pushes the
genre forward but then what about those
other four nominations does Hogwarts
Legacy have a chance to sneak in there
we also have to remember we still have
several months left in the year with
Heavy Hitters like Spider-Man 2
Assassin's Creed Mirage lures of the
Fallen Super Mario Brothers wonder and
Alan Wake too I could see any of those
scoring very well and getting into the
game of the year conversation for a
moment though let's just pretend the
year ended right now would Hogwarts
Legacy even then have a chance to sneak
into one of those other four nominations
honestly right now I think it probably
should remember the nominations aren't
based purely on review score after all
stray had a Metacritic rating of 83 and
a plague tale Requiem 82 for what it's
worth Eldon ring scored a 96 the highest
of them all and was the eventual winner
then again in my humble opinion I think
Elden ring is one of the best games ever
made and then we also have to keep in
mind the competition wasn't quite as
fierce in 2020 too so of all these games
we mentioned so far I do think we should
immediately roll out the remix heck
Metroid Prime is one of my favorite
games ever made and the Remake is
fantastic but I still think for an
annual award you should focus on
recognizing original games released that
year unless there's just something so
incredibly new and different being done
on a remake for an old game fighting
games are probably a bit too Niche for
the overall Game of the Year I've also
seen a lot of love for Remnant sea of
stars and armored Core if it was up to
me personally picking I'd definitely
have Hogwarts Legacy in there at least
for a nomination but making a prediction
though on what will actually be
nominated I think it's going to miss the
cut now despite all of this no matter
how the game of the year voting goes
Hogwarts Legacy is highly likely to
finish 2023 in the number one spot in at
least one category and maybe the most
important one of all sales numbers and
this my friends if they managed to do
this would be a truly incredible feat
the last time a game not named Call of
Duty topped the Us sales charts for a
full year was 2018. the title to do it
oh just a little game called Red Dead
Redemption 2 now it's been a while since
we received official numbers for
Hogwarts Legacy but every time there's
even a small update it's always more
info pointing to the fact that the game
is still selling incredibly well back in
July we had this article from
gamesindustry.biz which wrote Hogwarts
Legacy is Comfortably the biggest
selling game for the first half of the
year across Europe its sales are 69
bigger than what Eldon ring managed over
the same period which was the
best-selling game during the first half
of 2022. they've also been running
promotions recently discounting the game
and it seems that those are absolutely
having their intended effect and sales
are surging there was a 214 spike in
sales on the Xbox series X and S with
those recent deals now in terms of the
official numbers that we received we
know that Hogwarts Legacy sold 12
million copies in its first two weeks
alone then in May the Warner Brothers
Discovery CEO David zaslav said the game
had sold over 15 million units earning
more than 1 billion in sales and just to
try and put these numbers into context
because I think especially people new to
gaming may not realize how incredible
this actually is here's a list of the
best-selling games on the PS4 4 from the
NPD group back in 2019. now it's
important to remember the PS5 was not
out yet but the PS4 air it was kind of
winding down here and at the time of
that posting in 2019 we know Spider-Man
had sold just north of 13 million copies
that's right 13 million and it was the
sixth best-selling PS4 game of all time
we now know as of June 2022 the
Spider-Man series on Playstation has
reached 33 million in sales but that
includes the original release on PS4
plus the remastered Edition on PS5 and
even the spin-off game Miles Morales and
that 15 million number for legacy is
months old at this point we still
haven't received an update on any new
number since the PS4 and Xbox One
versions released back in May plus
they're still planning to release the
title on Nintendo switch in November of
this year and according to WB themselves
they're expecting even bigger things
from the switch version given its
massive install base my point in all of
this is that I actually think Hogwarts
Legacy as a franchise and what it's done
in terms of reaching so many people may
actually be a bit underrated in the
industry this is a title that became
wb's fifth 1 billion plus gaming
franchise joining only Mortal Kombat
Game of Thrones the Lego games and DC so
can any game catch Hogwarts Legacy here
in 2023 honestly I think there are
probably only two games with a shot at
surpassing it this year Spider-Man 2
because there is so much hype for that
game pretty much anybody with a PS5 is
going to be picking it up at some point
and then of course Call of Duty the
thing about Spider-Man 2 though is it's
only releasing on PS5 so it's gonna have
quite the uphill climb to catch Legacy
which by the end of the year will be
available on every major platform you
know they're going to be doing plenty of
holiday sales as well which is only
going to further increase that number it
will be fascinating to see how the
numbers end up shaking out for the rest
of the year and when WB finally decides
to share more official numbers with us I
gotta be honest with you guys not only
is Hogwarts like is he going to be one
of the best selling games of the year I
think it's on track to being one of the
best-selling games of all time and with
all of this incredible success there has
to be more from Hogwarts Legacy coming
right DLC sequel what we're actually
still waiting on an official
announcement for a possible Hogwarts
Legacy DLC or sequel we do know the team
at Avalanche gave us prize announcement
about something that we can expect from
Hogwarts Legacy later this year I
explain what that is in the video on the
left side of your screen now so check
that one out next as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon